frau teichert wer kontrolliert
eigentlich ob die bürger jetzt diese
quarantäne pflicht einhalten
wer schafft das flächendeckend ist das
natürlich nicht nicht und ich schaffe
bei den ganzen tests die wir machen
natürlich über die kontaktpersonen
ermittlungen haben gesundheitsamt hat
natürlich kontakt zu den leuten den
quarantäne sind da wären ja auch
symptome abgefragt und so weiter aber
ich glaube nicht dass es bei der großen
anzahl die der testsieger jetzt
durchführen
möglich ist das was nach fünf erfolgen
auch nicht mit behörden hilfe von
anderer seite
da muss man auch glaube ich einfach
nochmal an die bürgerinnen und bürger
appellieren und das ist mir ganz wichtig
jeder hat auch seine eigene
verantwortung und jeder muss sich auch
so verhalten dass wir mit dem virus gut
leben können denn das ist die zentrale
botschaft frage an den biologen herr
schmidt chanasit seit wochen reden wir
auch über schnelltests über pult es zum
dieses lange warten auf die ergebnisse
dieses pcr-test eben zu überwinden
darum geht es nicht voran er ist nicht
ganz so trivial so ein schnelltest für
den direkten virus nachweis zu
entwickeln bei den antikörpern gegen hat
schneller dort sind ja auch
entsprechende taste verfügbar
weiß dass verschiedene firmen hatte
durch intensiv daran forschen und es
gilt das weiter zu unterstützen
und dann wäre so ein antigen schnelltest
quasi im format eines
schwangerschaftstest es gerade in den
händen der amtsärztin ein hervorragendes
werkzeug um die quarantänezeit zu
verkürzen oder eben auch die bürgerinnen
zu bewegen einfach dann auch zu hause zu
bleiben
denn je schneller so ein ergebnis
mitgeteilt wird ich glaube dass so
größer ist dann auch die zustimmung wenn
ich weiß ich bin positiv dann bleibe ich
natürlich auch zu hause als wenn ich ihm
eine woche auf etwas warten muss
insofern wäre das ein großer schritt
nach vorne eine große erleichterung für
die arbeit der gesundheits samt geräten
gleich noch darüber wo des da klemmt
frau dreyer jetzt wird natürlich auch
gesagt wer feiern war in kroatien oder
auf mallorca oder irgendwie in bulgarien
der sollte seinen corona test selber
bezahlen wünscht sich auch erlauben
sagen sie das ist richtig also ich habe
großes verständnis das ist jetzt erst
mal so gemacht worden ist es musste
schnell gehen aber ich finde dezidiert
wir brauchen eine neue strategie in den
herbst reisenden wieder ferien sind ich
meine dass die volksseele wirklich kocht
an der stelle und zwar zu recht wenn man
menschen im fernsehen sieht
die am flughafen sagen ich weiß mallorca
ist ein risikogebiet aber ich war
trotzdem hin
und dann soll der staat sozusagen noch
den test bezahlen und das geht nicht ich
denke wir brauchen eine neue strategie
ich glaube tatsächlich risikogebiete
dass es richtig ist dass wenn die
menschen zurück kommen dass sie in
quarantäne gehen dass der test auch
nicht am ersten tag innerhalb von 72
stunden gemacht wird sondern irgendwann
am 5 6 und 7
und wenn die leute in den test machen
sollen sie ihn bezahlen und wenn sie
ihnen nicht bezahlen wollen dann plant
halb 14 tage in quarantäne
ich glaube tatsächlich wir müssen neu
überlegen so oder ähnlich und das sollte
einer der wichtigen aufträge seien wenn
wir jetzt wieder und treffen was ja
überfällig ist gemeinsam im kreis der
ministerpräsidenten und der kanzlerin in
der bundesregierung dass man wirklich
nochmals sorgfältig überlegt wie geht
man mit dieser frage um auf dauer kann
es nicht sein wenn menschen bewusst in
risikogebiete fahren um urlaub zu machen
dass am ende die allgemeinheit diese
tests bezahlen
da ist es natürlich auch eine
definitionsfrage wenn man sich die
zahlen von gesamt spanien anschaut sind
die gar nicht mehr so hoch aber
offensichtlich wirklich betroffen ist
der balkan herr laumann und die türkei
kann man menschen die nach langer zeit
jetzt mal zu ihren familien wieder
gereist sind kann man den
vergnügungssucht vorwerfen
das tun wir ja auch nicht aber also das
ist jetzt so machen wie wir's machen sie
es richtig wenn ich mir vorstellen
würden sie müssen jetzt noch bei den
testen auch das geld einsammeln
dann würden sie völlig scheitern dass
das ist gut dass es jetzt so ist und
dass wir dadurch kommen und wir haben ja
auch gesagt ist muss getestet werden da
hatten die meisten leute ihre reisen
geplant oder waren sie schon angetreten
für die jetzt im moment ist das richtig
aber ich meine wenn wir das einmal da
ist mittelfristig sehen dass wir uns
wieder nicht weggehen ist uns ja noch
viele monate beschäftigen vielleicht
sogar noch in das nächst weit in das
nächste jahr hinein ich weiß es nicht
das dann irgendwo bei den kosten einer
reise in ein risikogebiet auch die test
kostet eingerechnet werden müssen
das finde ich dann auch weil man es ist
einfach nicht aufgabe finde ich alles in
der solidargemeinschaft in dieser frage
laden zu lassen
so aber war kann es ja nur in ein
strukturiertes verfahren machen und dann
kann man das finde ich auch
so organisieren dass das war den
menschen auch stück eine
selbstverständlichkeit wir das zu machen
ich weiß da keine zeit nicht jemand
vergnügungssucht vor wenn menschen das
ist ja auch in nordrhein westfalen ein
thema die ihre wurzeln nun mal zum
beispiel in der türkei haben dass die
einmal im jahr ein bedürfnis haben nach
hause zu fahren und verwandtschaft zu
müssen weil sie haben dafür wird ein
kredit ist die das bezahlen
die türkei ist risikogebiet seit juli
ich habe immer gesagt wir müssen auf
dauer zu einer lösung komme und ich habe
immer gesagt wir brauchen eine lösung
zum beispiel im zusammenhang mit den
buchungen von reisen dass dann diese
kosten drin sind okay also darüber
werden sie auch mit der politik noch
reden oder als politiker mit der
bundeskanzlerin in der nächsten runde
reden freiheit trotzdem nochmal zum
verständnis die frage natürlich teile
kroatien sind nun heute zum risikogebiet
erklärt worden
luxemburg ist runter von der liste des
hat sich frau dreyer sehr gewünscht in
spanien gibt es tatsächlich moment in
ganz spanien zahlen im hunderter bereich
denken sie der gibt's einen
ermessenspielraum wer wann risikogebiet
ist also ich glaube nicht dass es da ein
ermessensspielraum gibt das wird ja klar
gelistet aber ich glaube dass es
insgesamt sehr schwierig ist sich immer
aktuell informieren zu müssen sie müssen
ja überlegen den gesundheitsämtern die
müssen ja immer gucken das heißt sie
müssen tagesaktuell chatten welche
gebiete sind jetzt dabei gut wenn es
denn dann durch die medien kommt dann
hat man dass er so drauf aber es ist
natürlich eine ganze liste und wir
hatten gerade das thema test strategie
ich finde es auch gut wenn wir die tests
strategie noch mal überlegen und
anpassen würden und ich glaube es wäre
wichtig wenn wir einheitliche lösungen
schaffen
das schwierige ist es gibt im moment
eben eine ganze liste von
ausnahmesituationen also nicht nur wenn
sie aus dem risikogebiet kommen auch
wenn sie bei der wahl eine warnung haben
zum beispiel dann wird auch der test
bezahlt natürlich selbstverständlich
auch wenn sie symptome haben ja und da
muss man das erstmal immer alles
abdecken das ist sehr aufwendig das
verfahren und ich glaube es wäre gut
werden eine einheitliche strategie die
die leute auch gut verstehen können wir
steigen noch mal ein bisschen mehr ein
dass die zahlen in deutschland hoch gene
hat nicht nur mit den reiserückkehrern
zu tun
viele sprechen von
einer zweiten welle tun sie das
eigentlich zu recht die gefahr in der
zweiten welle ist real ist sie schon da
kommt sie noch also die frage ob wir in
einer zweiten welle sind oder ob sie
kommt die halte ich für wenig
zielführend tatsächlich steigen die
zahlen in deutschland obwohl wir so
niedrig waren sehen wir jetzt für den
anstieg und der anstieg hängt ja nur
damit zusammen dass wir nachlässig
geworden sind und so steigt auch die
nervosität die mahnungen werden lauter
kroner wird jeden tag gefährlicher sind
zunehmend als die spätfolgen langsam
sichtbar fehlt es an disziplin die
kanzlerin will die zügel anziehen wenn
ich gesagt habe die zügel anziehen dann
meine ich damit dass eben auch sehr
konsequent die regeln einfach
durchgesetzt werden müssen wenn nicht
drohe ein desaster mahnt merkel
und was sagen die zahlen die
neuinfektionen pro tag liegen fast
überall deutlich unter 50 pro 100.000
einwohner
der wert liegt im wochenschnitt bei 1,08
heute meldet das robert-koch-institut
1707 neuinfektionen
gleichzeitig befinden sich 231 corona
patienten auf der intensivstation
ja und ich muss gleich noch einmal
korrigieren in ganz spanien sind es über
6.000 neue infizierte auf mallorca waren
die zahlen im hunderter bereich und
jetzt sind wir frau dreyer bei den
deutschen teil 1707 neuinfizierte aber
nur 231 menschen auf intensivstationen
muss man da ein desaster befürchten
übertreibt die bundeskanzlerin
also nach meiner aus nach meiner ansicht
ist es so dass wir das eine ernst nehmen
müssen dass die zahlen ansteigen
aber wir müssen auch keine panik wir
haben eine völlig andere situation als
wir sie im märz april hatten wir haben
wahnsinnig viel gelernt in der
zwischenzeit wir haben viele viele
erfahrungen unser gesundheitssystem ist
innerhalb kürzester zeit hochgerüstet
worden wir haben sofort programme auf
den weg gegeben und wir haben mit dem
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst wirklich
gelernt was bedeutet nachverfolgung und
das ist ja jetzt auch die große stärke
so lange wir die kontrolle darüber haben
dass wir nachverfolgen können müssen wir
keine panik haben aber wir sollten schon
appellieren dass wir die regeln
einhalten müssen es ist schon wichtig
dass die leute auch wieder zurückkommen
zu dem bewusstsein abstand halten maske
tragen ist alles sehr sehr wichtig aber
keine panik amt sondern darauf achten
diese regeln auch einhalten und deutlich
machen wir haben jetzt nicht die gefahr
dass die krankenhäuser überlastet werden
aber wir müssen auf unseren öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst achten weil wir den im
moment wahnsinnig viel zumuten und wenn
wir irgendwo an kapazitätsgrenzen stoßen
könnten dann dort und wir brauchen den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst dringend
auch um nachverfolgen zu können in
zukunft dass das alles ist in zukunft
noch schaffen vorher die frage an herrn
laumann noch mal nach der
bundeskanzlerin sie waren vor einem
desaster markus söder sagt corona wird
jeden tag gefährlicher und
heimtückischer als zunächst angenommen
ist das angemessen in ihren augen oder
ist es alarmismus
das ist cannabis muss sondern es ist so
werden die nachlässigkeit immer stärker
zunimmt
dann können wir schon in ein großes
problem kommen und wir müssen jetzt
finde ich die anfänge wären wo es
nachlässigkeiten gibt also wer zum also
das was getragen zum beispiel im
öffentlichen nahverkehr ist ein muss und
es muss
gesetzt werden die frage nach verfolgung
wir können auch nicht den gesamten
straßenverkehr tag und nacht überwacht
aber jeder der auto fährt weiß wenn man
zu schnell auto fährt kann man erwischt
werden und jeder von uns denkt an dieses
chris kennt auch jemand der schon
erwischt worden ist
und wenn quarantäne nicht eingehalten
wird muss es sich herumsprechen dass man
auch mal jemand erwischt hat und der
dafür auch eine strafe bezahlt hat sonst
behalten wir die problematik nicht in
den griff ich denke das hat die
bundeskanzlerin
da zum ausdruck bringen wollen und sie
hat ja auch gesagt bevor wir neue
verschärfungen machen müssen die regeln
die wir uns gegeben haben eingehalten
werden wissen sie wenn leute sagen das
tragen von mascus ist gegen meine
freiheit
ich finde freiheit ohne verantwortung
gibt es nicht und was getragen ist ein
zeichen dass wir viel freiheit machen
können aber eben die verantwortung auch
haben uns und andere zu schützen und
freiheit und verantwortung hat
wenigstens in meinem menschenbild immer
zusammengehört herr schmidt chanasit
frage auch an den virologen die
intensivbetten belegung war so ein
parameter für uns der erwert waren
parameter die neue infektion waren und
sind ein parameter würden sie denn im
angesicht dieser aktuellen zahlen die
wir vorhin auch noch mal zitiert haben
würden sie denn tatsächlich sagen dass
die sorge berechtigt ist dass uns diese
pandemie noch mal außer kontrolle
geraten kann
also ich teile absolut diese sachliche
darstellung deutschland verfolgt das
konzept der stabilen kontrolle das ist
die strategie und die funktioniert
natürlich man darf das nicht überreizen
und genau der wunde punkt sind die
gesundheitsämter das was vor drei er
gesagt hat das heißt man muss von
unserer seite
von der politischen seite dafür sorgen
dass das eben nicht geschieht und dass
man sagt mal sauber trennen
von den maßnahmen auf bevölkerungs ebene
und da hat sich eben nichts geändert
dort gibt es die aha regeln die ja nun
mehrmals erwähnt wurden masken in dem
stimmten bereich muss ganz wichtig ist
ja auch zu verwenden und damit sind wir
bisher gut durchgekommen und das hat ja
auch dazu führt dass wir nicht einen
sehr steilen anstieg der zahlen sehen
momentan sondern dass das stück für
stück das ist genau die ursachen es ist
eben eine ganz andere situation als im
märz aber innerhalb weniger tage quasi
das exponentielle wachstum hatten und da
sieht man dass diese strategie
funktioniert
und wir alles dafür tun müssen dass die
kollegen die neben mir sitzt auch weiter
so gut ihre arbeiten genauso ring kann
dann auch noch mal infrage an die
allgemeinmedizinerin warum frau zeit
gibt es immer mehr infizierte aber noch
nicht wesentlich mehr menschen die
intensivpatienten sind na ja ich würde
jetzt mal kess sagen und natürlich weil
die kontaktperson nachverfolgung so gut
funktioniert weil die gesundheitsämter
so gut arbeiten sich auch selber ja also
da haben wir ein system auf das wir uns
verlassen können und wenn man die
rechtzeitig sozusagen in quarantäne
schickt können sie auch keinen neuen
mehr anstecken das muss man auch sehen
das ist ein großer erfolg und das ist
die strategie die wir ja auch verfolgen
so und dann bleibt ja aber die frage
herr schmidt chanasit virologen kollegen
von ihnen haben die hoffnung und
menschen sowieso dass dieses virus
insgesamt auch weniger gefährlich werden
könnte
es gibt ja es gibt es anzeichen dafür
also es gibt da ja nun wo das vermutet
wurde wo es auch schon erste hinweise
gibt dass man dann eben nicht mehr so
schwer erkrankt aber es gibt nach wie
vor eine große große vielfalt an
verschiedenen varianten dieses neuen
corona virus das auch in deutschland
nach zirkuliert und das bedeutet eben
darauf hin dass ich jetzt nicht eine
bestimmte variante durchgesetzt hätte
die nicht mehr so zu sagen die menschen
so schwer krank macht sondern dass das
was wir sehen das leben junger menschen
reisen dass junge menschen feiern und
wir die älteren oder die mit risiko von
ihm besonders gut schützen das uns und
vorteil hat das eben sehr gut gelungen
ist genau also das heißt das virus
breitet sich weiter aus auch durch alle
bevölkerungsschichten
es trifft auch häufiger jüngere und
damit ist auch belegt warum die zahl der
toten eben nicht proportional stadt
genauso ihr kollege professor steht man
nur um das auch noch mal zu zitieren er
sagte jetzt jüngst es gibt mehrere
hinweise
wir wissen aber nicht ob sich das neue
corona virus auch so verhält weil
eigentlich das virus ja kein interesse
haben kann den wirt zu töten und
bekannten coronaviren tun das auch nicht
so also das ist tatsächlich auch das
worüber die wissenschaft jetzt nachdenkt
und sich die verschiedenen mutationen
dieses virus anschaut dann muss ich das
in den entsprechenden tiermodellen dann
anschauen muss das eben auch in großen
kurorten sich anschauen welche korte ist
mit welcher variante
infiziert und treten dort eben schwere
fälle auf oder leichte fälle also das
hauptproblem ist ja eben nach wie vor
dass wir angst haben müssen dass ich in
kurzer zeit sehr viele menschen
infizieren kann eben auch seinen virus
was eigentlich nicht sozusagen eine
große anzahl von schweren infektionen
hervorrufen problematisch werden das ist
ja das kritische bei den jungs ja nicht
sagt eine ebola virus wohin der sehr
viele menschen daran sterben
und diese situation dass nach vor eben
noch nicht überwunden
herr laumann mit dem begriff der welle
wird ja nun auch über die zweite
gesprochen wurde ja immer der eindruck
erweckt dass das virus kommt und auch
wieder geht's hat die politik auch das
versäumt den menschen klarzumachen dass
wir eben genau wie sie heute sagen mit
dem virus wohl eher leben müssen nein
ich glaube dass politik und was ich mich
erinnern kann seit dem 25
februar jemand sagte das virus wird
nicht mehr verschwinden die welle da ist
er glaube ich mitgemeint gibt es wieder
ein lock down wie in mitte märz gemacht
haben ist ja ich glaube werden wir mitte
märz das gewusst hätten was wir jetzt
wissen ja hätten wir nicht so einen lock
down gemacht wie wiegen gemacht haben
schauen sie mal ich habe damals wirklich
nicht gewusst wie viel intensiv plätze
habe ich in nordrhein-westfalen wirklich
darüber gab es keine statistik wir haben
krankenhausplan ist das eine aber
begangen aus den betten aufgestellt habe
wusste kein mensch ich kann jetzt als
gesundheitsminister jeden morgen gucken
wie viel freie intensiv plätze hat
nordrhein westfalen war dieses defizits
team aufgebaut worden ist das sind
zurzeit rund 2100 alleine in unserem
bundesland nordrhein-westfalen oder
neben eine andere frage
ich glaube dass wir nicht vorher gedacht
haben wenn wir unsere krankenhäuser
einen brief schreiben das harbour
sechzehnter märz gemacht und gesagt
haben bitte verschiebt man alle
planbaren eingriffen die man medizinisch
guten gewissens verschieben kann dass
man drei vier tage später schon 25
prozent intensiv setzte in einem ganz
normalen krankenhaus frei hat das hat da
vorher keiner gewusst und wir haben
diesen lobenden gemacht weil wir alle
rhi auch ich eine riesenangst hatten
man hat auch die bilder von italien vor
augen dass unsere intensiv kapazitäten
insbesondere unsere beratungs kapazität
nicht ausreichen und wenn sie dann vor
der frage stehen die ja auch erst mit
mir besprochen haben er stellt euch mal
vor wir haben zu wenig war aber sie
hätte wie sollen sie entscheiden er
einst bekommt und wer nicht eins bekommt
dann kommt man schon in eine ja auch in
einer situation wo man eben alle
register zieht um das zu verhindern
ich habe in den tagen erlebt dass der
holländische gesundheitsminister mich
anrufen hat gesagt herr lange können sie
in guten zweistelligen bereich
holländische schwer beatmungspatienten
übernehmen ich hab gewusst mehrmals
macht und wir haben fast 60 übernommen
in der zeit dass wir die vier fünf
wochen in den krankenhäusern haben
werden
wissen sie da kann ich mich alles gut
dran erinnern heute würde glaube ich
politik ein lockdown vii mit im märz
gemacht haben so nicht wieder machen
sondern wir werden ihn wahrscheinlich
viel differenzierter auslegen können
okay und deswegen wird eine zweite welle
nicht so ein lock down sein sondern es
wird glaube ich sehr differenzierter
regionale entscheidungen geben und das
ist mir zu sagen ich glaube auch dass
wir darüber reden müssen dass nicht er
das erste reflex sein darf kindergärten
und schulen zu schließen dazu kommen wir
noch das verspreche ich auch und heilig
v3 ist ist ja interessant dass nicht nur
von dieser zweiten welle gesprochen wird
sondern auch immer wieder heute noch
gesagt wird wir müssen unbedingt an den
zweiten lockdown verhindern wird es den
überhaupt geben könnte sich selbst und
reiches land wie deutschland es sich
leisten ist es nicht auch irgendwie
etwas an die wand gemalt was sie sondern
geben wird also erstens könnten wir es
uns nicht leisten bin ich fest von
überzeugt das ist so nachhaltig die
folgen dieser zeit dass es wahnsinn
und das zweite ist ich glaube auch
überhaupt nicht daran dass es so weit
kommt wir haben einfach sehr viel
dazugelernt und es ist nicht
ausgeschlossen sie können da geschichten
von erzählen dass man regionale
situation hat dass man sagt man muster
intensiver reingehen was schließen
ähnliches betrifft aber in
flächendeckenden lockdown wie wir ihn
hatten ist aus meiner sicht eigentlich
nicht vorstellen